former Florida State former NFL player
drafted I think by the Titans back in
2010 out of Florida State
he's now dr. Myron role who joins us on
the program
doctor how are you I'm doing well thanks
for having me bad I appreciate it if you
can give us an idea of what the last
month has been like which and compare
that to any other month that you would
have on the job well it's been intense I
just I'm just coming off a 24 hour shift
but our Hospital has been transformed I
was walk-in it's almost like an airport
security line we have to have a mask
everyone regardless of your position or
title within the MGH National Hospital
community gets to wear this mask our
hallways are bare now because the
visitor policy has been restricted can
have any family members and visitors or
outpatient clinics are now done all
virtually we'll call our patients with
results as cat-scans and let them know
that we have to reschedule their cases
because operating rooms are canceling
elective cases were we doing emergent or
urgent cases on neurosurgical floor is
transformed to a coda thank you know
florida that there's this surge clinic
at the hospital in a hospital the sort
of offload some of the heavy influence
of patients that have come up with over
ninety or symptoms analogous to it so
you know i as a member surgery resident
I went into this passion of mine to
operate on the brain and spine and the
personal nerves but now myself or my
colleagues we've been redeployed and
redistributing on our skill set I guess
or just our our time and our energy to
helping fight this club in nineteen
Everett or this club in eighteen issue
that's happening at the hospital wide
approach and it's vastly different than
what we've seen in in Boston it's gonna
get worse probably the next week or two
so we're preparing for even even more
challenging days ahead but you go to med
school for neurosurgery but now you're
doing something with a virus that you
know you like it feels like you're going
back to medical school but you're doing
it in real time with real patients with
lives on the line that's right that's
right and you know I would say that it
is a change up certainly there are
some cars over trades between code 19
and there are surgeries for instance
surgeries that happen near the
scientists through the middle
transferred oils anything that can sort
of aerosolized particles that can
potentially infect classes as there are
surgeons we use a lot of electric artery
and high speed drills and our cases and
that has been shown to maybe aerosolized
some of the body fluids to potentially
infect us but you're right at baseline
you have to learn do when I do but sort
of relearn approaches to affect change
in this upper respiratory illness but I
think to our advantage
we're a teaching hospital and we had
wonderful medical doctors and such as do
doctors who really really stepping out
front and helping us sort of manage that
learning curve a little bit so we can
kind of come in and not have to do
anything outside truly outside of our
scope of practice like intubating
somebody urgently but you know be able
to handle some of the most fundamental
aspects with their care and it's really
just about manpower right now the
personnel we meet it at the hospital
level and we have to be able to advance
it adjust we had Tony Boselli on the
former NFL linemen Hall of Fame finalist
last couple years and he contracted the
corona virus and he said you know I'm
alone in a hospital room and I'm
thinking is this where I'm going to die
like going to your job you're seeing
people we're seeing this in New York
where you know the medical staff has to
almost choose who they can try to save
and who they can't I mean how do you how
do you process that doc that's very
difficult and it's uh it's even more
difficult when as mr. purselley said
when you're alone but you don't have
your family around because there's not
able to be there based on the hospital's
policy these end-of-life some goals of
care discussions are happening over the
phone and you're like man this is
unbelievable but I will say that you
know these patients have as you know a
lot of them do have comorbidities or
pre-existing conditions that already put
them in harm's way and make them very
high-risk subsets of the demographic and
when this Cova 19 hits it sort of sits a
little bit and then maybe after day five
or six or seven quickly decompensate so
it's challenging and I hope to every
story
that we're hearing that anecdotal story
that you're hearing allows people who
are maybe not connected to the
healthcare industry and that's back to
the hospital world you can see that this
is serious
this is real stay away from those
beaches that you're going to it says
convenience stay away from those highly
pompom you know frequented places that
are just full of people and and really
you'll do your part as as a normal
citizen sort of affect change in your
life because that's important for all of
us to do
he's dr. Myron role neurosurgery
resident at Harvard the mass
Massachusetts General Hospital a Rhodes
Scholar former NFL safety was it
sixth-round by the Titans that sound
right that's correct on yes sir
okay how close were you to staying with
football I'm very close I played
football my whole life that was six
years old my father is from Thomas but
my parents from the Palmer sir they
started the American Football League
back home and what we came to America
football was a huge part of my life
and my cousin Safari natural role played
NFL I went to the States because Bobby
Bowden had a pedigree of putting guys in
the anasazi on Sanders we love Butler
you know all these great great athletes
great corners and great safeties so when
the decision I had to be made whether I
was gonna stay continue to play or move
on to this next career I prayed about it
talked to my family and friends and
realized that practically I made that
money to pay for medical school also my
hands were still healthy enough to
actually operate because I always wanted
to be a neurosurgeon and I didn't have
any questions or tried a brain injury
that would prevent me from thinking you
know clearly as I went over in my next
career so I made the tough choice went
ahead and went to medicine and it's been
a blessing because now I'm able to
advocate now for football as well in a
confession spectrum but then also be
able to take care of people who are very
sick right moments like this I how
concerned are you that you're going to
contract the corona virus I'm very
concerned we all are certainly I try to
protect myself every time I go into a
patient's room you know there's the
thing is coronaviruses doesn't just hit
one patient and that's like the only
college ii or malady that they have
right so they call this as a
neurosurgeon
this patient may have a brain booth or a
brain tumor or a tumor in their spine or
some sort of neurosurgical disease
burdens but they also have cloven 19 so
I welcome to these rooms I try to
protect myself as best as I can
I go in get my physical exam quickly get
my history quickly be efficient get all
my tasks done so I don't have to
re-enter the room five or six seven
times to potentially expect myself I got
married four months ago and I sent my
wife down now Mandy with her we with our
sister you know so I'm trying to make
sure I'm not bringing anything home to
her so yeah I'm just trying to make
address within my own life so I cable to
protect myself from protective people
around me being a neurosurgery I'm
curious about you know the future of new
helmets and the NFL concussions I get if
the has the NFL ask you about this or
you know looking for you to advise and
maybe how we make a new helmet that can
protect the brain even more they have
not asked me and I would certainly love
for them to reduce hell cuz I love the
sport so much for sure I wanted to stay
around it helped me so much it's helped
my family I'm using the trace that
football taught me as a physician that
anytime I mentor the young kids from
Florida State who I talk to I tell them
that if you have interests and science
or medicine or just helping people
really think about being a physician or
a physician assistant nurse practitioner
or something in health care because it's
the crossover is just really seamless
but yeah I would certainly love to help
partake in do technology in new ways
innovative ways to find out how to make
the game safer and all levels
particularly in a young football Yong
Yong Li top corner the Youth Football
League because I think that's where it
really starts you know you sort of have
this buildup of chronic hits to the head
that you know maybe just gets
illuminated
once you get to you know the high
velocity impacts of high level college
football or maybe professional football
but I think it starts young so if you
look back kind of go upstream and try to
figure things out that way we might be
able to rectify the situation keep the
game space and preserve it you're kind
of a show-off here for old grade point
average in high school I think you had
the lead role in Fiddler on the Roof the
musical you go to Oxford you're a Rhodes
Scholar you're kind of a ball hog
No you know if it's sure that was I did
not sink well as a white brush or stuff
we found something you don't do well
okay thank you go get some sleep and we
appreciate what you're doing Thank You
doc all right thanks I appreciate you
that's dr. Myron role